street battles have raged for four days
in Yemen's second city Aden since Houthi
rebels took over the capital Sana'a in
2015
Aden has been the seat of the country's
internationally recognized government
now key areas including the presidential
palace have fallen to southern
separatists
analysts say their goal is to win back
the independence the South lost on the
two Yemen's United in 1990 this is what
they have been fighting for since 2007
[Music]
years now since they have been demanding
the separation and the moment now is is
there and I think also the the regional
and national and the international
circumstances will be in this is what is
highly likely to happen the separation
this flag represented South Yemen when
it was independent between 1967 until
1998 group Doctors Without Borders is
calling the city a battlefield after
dozens of their soldiers were killed in
a Houthi attack on August the first
sudden separatists accused the
internationally recognized and
saudi-backed president of failing to
protect them and called for the
government to be overthrown many people
have fled Aden others are trapped in
their homes including this aid worker we
hear the sense of mortar shells from
time to time without knowing the source
or the target to be hit some houses in
the city are directly hit or fire
fragments enter the houses or the cars
for example a group of men sitting in a
cafe yesterday were hit by a mortar
shell the battling sites were once part
of a saudi-led coalition they've been
fighting Houthi rebels in northern and
western Yemen for more than four years
the latest violence threatens to open a
new front in the five-year war which has
killed tens of thousands of people
Nora Burton Manley al Jazeera